today's video is sponsored by keeps
believe it or not hair loss is a problem
that affects over 60 percent of men and
while there is no magic cure for
baldness you can prevent hair loss from
happening in the first place keeps is a
subscription service where you can
tailor an fda approved solution to your
specific stage of hair loss
unfortunately it is a bit late for me
keeps can only stop hair loss not
regenerate hair so it's best to take
action in the early stages of hair loss
most people see results in around six
months once your treatment plan is
established your products are sent to
you every three months with the correct
amounts for daily use at half the cost
of the pharmacy they also have online
medical support because hair loss is a
medical issue and you need to be sure
that the hair loss is not a symptom of
something more serious but don't just
take our word for it head to their
website and check the reviews for before
and after photos of real men who've had
success with this program so if this is
a problem that is bothering you or
someone you care about and you have a us
address remember hair loss stops with
keeps take action now and get 50 off
your first order at keeps.com
visualpolitik or click on the link in
the description that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash visualpolitik
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
since the beginning of the invasion of
ukraine russian troops have suffered
major setbacks for example they have had
to abandon the siege of kiev after
several weeks trying to take the
ukrainian capital so at this point i
think there are some questions that rang
out loud and clear why is the russian
army performing so poorly how is it
possible that they've not been able to
take any cities in today's video we are
not going to talk about the atrocities
committed by the russian army we are
going to focus on military strategy and
purely technical issues think of it this
way this is the ukrainian army and this
is the russian army in other words there
should be no point of comparison here
russia has a far superior military than
ukraine what's more if anything
characterizes putin's russia it's the
militaristic culture
we've already talked about it here on
visualpolitik the kremlin has even built
a cathedral dedicated to its armed
forces we all kind of expected that in a
matter of days russian soldiers would
capture kiev and the main ukrainian
cities however after more than a month
russia has not been able to take a
single major city according to some
sources during the first month of the
invasion alone russia suffered more than
20 000 casualties to give you an idea
these figures exceed the casualties
suffered by the us army during the
entire 20 years of the war in
afghanistan of course the ukrainians are
also suffering hedging casualties but
that is kind of to be expected
supposedly those who had all the aces up
their sleeves were the russians in other
words the russian military already had
several failures in its history but we
all expected that putin's reforms were
working and what failures are we talking
about
from georgia to chechnya all the wars
the russian federation have fought have
been bitter victories yes russia won the
chechen wars by the cost of losing
thousands of soldiers i know what many
of you are thinking this is anti-russian
propaganda but that's not the case
vladimir putin himself was aware that
his army was not ready for a modern war
and that's why in 2008 the kremlin put
all of its resources into bringing its
army into the 21st century for this
putin counted on two key figures sergey
soju the minister of defense and valerie
jerazimov the chief of the general staff
of the russian armed forces i want to
tell you to keep this name fresh in your
mind valerie gerasimov if you are a
long-time follower of us here on
visualpolitik and if you're not
subscribe down here this name will be
familiar to you he is a military rock
star respected throughout the military
community even by his nato adversaries
many would say he is the intellectual
father of the next generation warfare
concept in fact we all thought that with
jerasimov at the helm the russian armed
forces would abandon the soviet heritage
and enter the 21st century however we
are seeing that in russia the old adage
that was so often repeated in soviet
times still persists
people pretend to work and the
government pretends to pay old soviet
proverb say what you like about the
soviets they had some good sayings in
today's video we're going to avoid
focusing on the war in ukraine nor are
we going to talk about russian weapons
we'll leave all of that for two more
videos we'll be doing in the future but
the question we're asking today is why
is the russian military such a mess what
exactly is wrong with the russian armed
forces how is it possible for such an
authoritarian country with such a
militaristic culture to have such a
disorganized military today we're gonna
answer all these questions but first
let's look at some history
[Music]
lack of training
[Music]
we've all seen pictures of russian
soldiers captured by ukrainians
ukrainian propaganda has taken upon
itself to spread these images with great
fanfare for all of us to see how they
phone their mothers however there is
something very interesting about all
these images almost all of the soldiers
are very young in most of them the
soldiers are not even 20 years old and
this indicates one thing they are
soldiers with very little training this
goes some way to explaining why russian
troops are dropping like flies in the
face of ukrainian fire and it also helps
explain news stories like this one
kharkiva blast two russian soldiers came
to the ukrainian police to ask for
diesel fuel in fairness i've definitely
done dumber things when i was 20. of
course this news is pure ukrainian
propaganda but it is one more example of
the many we have seen let's put it
plainly russia has a very serious
problem when it comes to training its
soldiers most of its troops are
conscripts during compulsory military
service to give you an idea it is
estimated that a quarter of russia's
elite troops the so-called spetsnaz are
conscripts and why is that you may ask
to understand this we have to go back to
the times of the soviet union
in those years compulsory military
service was two years virtually all
soviet men had to serve in the army when
they came of age this had an advantage
the soviet union had a lot of soldiers
but there is a problem two years is not
enough time to train for modern warfare
after world war ii the great powers
mainly the united states and the soviet
union entered into an arms race the more
complex the weapons the more training
time they require this explains why
fewer and fewer countries have
compulsory military service for several
decades now almost all armies have made
a huge effort and russia is no exception
in 2008 the kremlin reduced compulsory
military service in addition the army
launched a huge recruitment campaign
they wanted to hire soldiers who were
willing to forge a career in the
military professional soldiers who could
serve in the army for several years to
gain the necessary experience in modern
warfare to recruit soldiers you need two
things money and people who want to
enlist two things that are in short
supply in russia
to give you an idea today the russian
army has about 850 000 troops of these
only 405 000 are professional soldiers
and these professional soldiers do not
last many years in the army for example
a nato sergeant can serve an average of
15 to 20 years in russia is rare to find
soldiers who have served more than four
to illustrate this another way a fighter
pilot in nato has to fly for more than
200 hours in order to be combat ready in
russia a hundred hours is enough and i
know what many of you might be thinking
why don't they have a similar problem
and say
israel we all know that israel has
compulsory military service both israeli
men and women have to save in the army
for two years however no one would say
that israeli troops are poorly trained
so what does israel have that russia
doesn't have well we're gonna look at
that now
[Applause]
an army without sergeants
in general terms we could say that there
are two ways to enter an army as a
soldier or as an officer officers are
trained in academies in this respect
russia can give any other army a run for
its money russian admirals colonels and
generals are trained on par with those
of any other country again no one doubts
the professionalism of such a figure as
general valerie garasimov the problem is
that an army needs more than recruits
and officers in between there is a key
figure the non-commissioned officer the
nco in other words the sergeants
sergeants are soldiers with years of
experience who can train new recruits
they are key area in any army and this
is where russia has a very serious
problem think about it this way it is
estimated that only one percent of
recruits re-enlist in the army after
doing military service this means that
there are very few sergeants who can
train new soldiers so why doesn't anyone
want to re-enlist in the russian army
aren't they supposed to have a
militaristic culture that glorifies the
exports of their armed forces
[Music]
remember that putin has even gone so far
as to create youth militants this means
in theory russian soldiers have more
patriotic fever than any other country
and yes it is true the dream of many
young men is to enlist and serve the
motherland but once they get in the army
they are faced with a nightmare remember
this word dead of sheena check it out
russian soldier shoots dead eight
colleagues at siberian military base
this soldier in question shot his fellow
soldiers after suffering months of
hazing and abuse dead of china is the
russian word for hazing to give you an
idea in 2006 suicide was the cause of
death for 40 of peacetime soldiers in
2014 15 recruits died from hazing as you
can imagine with such a toxic culture it
makes sense that most russian soldiers
do not last more than four years in the
army in fact in 2009 russia opened its
first nco academy to try and fill the
shortage of sergeants but this is not
enough every year 2 000 new ncos
graduate and russia needs many more than
that in the absence of well-trained
sergeants they end up with battalions
led by conscripts with one year of
experience so as often happened in the
soviet union young generals pretended to
lead their battalions and conscripts
pretended to obey and you may ask is it
really vladimir putin's fault that the
russian army is performing so poorly why
is this much talked about army reform
and the kremlin consisted of where is
general valerie garasimov's influence
well check this out
all the president's men
the question you were all wondering now
is how could putin have made such a
miscalculation everything indicates that
russia expected a blitzkrieg they even
thought that the ukrainian army would
not resist and the civilians would
welcome the russian liberators with open
arms evidently this was not the case
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the question is was there no
intelligence service advising vladimir
putin remember that we are not talking
about a small miscalculation but about a
fully fledged invasion in which russia
has accumulated more than twenty
thousand casualties strange as it may
seem everything suggests that there is
in fact not in fact the supposed
disappearance of valerie garasimov is
striking he is the rock star of the
russian army something like the russian
version of general petraeus in the
united states so is it really realistic
to think that putin is micromanaging the
war in ukraine i mean it wouldn't be the
first time that a politician has
micromanaged a war we saw it during the
vietnam war in that case then u.s
president lyndon b johnson went so far
as to manage the minutes of details from
the oval office the result was an
absolute embarrassment for the u.s
military
when it comes to the war in ukraine the
russian army hasn't appointed a central
commander till april right after their
defeat in kiev the new
commander-in-chief of the war in ukraine
is general alexander devorkanov he used
to manage the russian intervention in
syria and he was the head of the army in
the southern region still it is unclear
how much decision-making power will he
have and how much putin will interfere
with his work
also think about it this way over the
years russia has evolved into a
personalistic dictatorship and that
affects the military as well think of it
this way during the soviet era russia
was an unmitigated dictatorship however
the main decision making bali was the
politburo a central committee of the
communist party it could have up to 35
members who discussed all decisions
today the soviet politburo no longer
exists and now we have this
it may look like a caricature but
everything points to the same thing a
personalist dictatorship a political
system where one man has the power to
make all decisions without a
counterweight and yes this is noticeable
in the military for example in almost
all countries the armed forces are
headed by the high general staff which
in turn reports to the ministry of
defense however russia has a special
army as well a kind of praetorian guard
for putin we are talking about the
national guard known by the name
rosgardia
[Music]
this body was created by putin himself
in 2016 as more than 340 000 troops and
is led directly by vladimir putin in
other words more than a third of all of
those 850 000 russian soldiers are
outside the regular army that is they do
not report to general jurasimov they
take direct orders from the president it
may surprise you but this is a constant
in almost all authoritarian regimes many
of you would think the military
functions better in a militaristic
dictatorship than in a democracy however
authoritarian leaders rarely fully trust
their military that explains why putin
has created his own praetorian guard
[Music]
in principle this national guard is not
a body designed to fight in war you
could say that they are kind of
militarized police their objective is to
safeguard the territorial control of
russia itself that is to fight against
insurgent groups terrorist groups and to
suppress protests and remember that
officially russia is not at war right
according to the kremlin the invasion of
ukraine is a special military operation
to denazify a territory full of
anti-russian insurgents conclusion putin
is most likely trying to send in the
national guard and that explains news
headlines like this one
two members of roscovardia were sacked
for refusing to join the invasion think
about it the national guard is not
trained for war as such sending them to
the front is a death sentence for many
of them but remember that we are talking
about an entire political system
centered around the figure of vladimir
putin who would dare to argue with them
at this point think of it this way
practically all the key figures in the
military and the military industry are
hand-picked by the president his party
united russia holds almost all the seats
in parliament out of 450 seats in the
russian duma 325 belong to putin's party
in other words there are no checks and
balances on the kremlin's power what
this means is that no one can question
putin's own miscalculations including
the invasion of ukraine
at this point no one can deny that putin
has miscalculated his forces he expected
that his troops would conquer keiv in a
few days and the ukrainians would
welcome russians with open arms in a
democracy the intelligence services
would have been free to inform the
president they could contradict him and
explain to him the reality on the ground
the generals themselves could prepare a
realistic strategy based on a more
thorough knowledge of their military
muscle but in this case what we are
seeing is a former kgb officer with no
military training making decisions
without anyone standing up to him and
that explains failures like this one
russian troops pull back from areas near
kiev ukrainian officials say once again
putin is pretending that the invasion of
ukraine is not a war and he expects his
national guard and army to pretend to
fight a special operation the question
now is to what extent will the old
soviet proverb still work will we really
see the russian army reorganize and try
to attack kiev again to what extent
could russia win this war without having
to use its nuclear or chemical weapons
you can leave me your answer in the
comments below and as always don't
forget that here on visualpolitik we
release new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel and hit the
little bell button down there so you
don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know and
i'll see you next time
you